did you ever have any real jobs like
regular jobs like like I mean
wait for it I just heard no no no
it makes total sense by the way I mean
like in life like a normal average I've
had a lot of like normal jobs you're
just no no of course you're right and
you play it's fun it's being a musician
same thing yeah a fake but no but we do
no but I mean I'm not like actually
playing like someone I'm not in the
military I'm not actually playing I'm
not doing those I'm not that thing I'm
playing it but so it's not he's a little
not real but I just met like a yeah a
normal job I got it like I worked at
Papa John's apology no I didn't work at
Papa John's okay I was uh a lifeguard oh
no that's a yeah yeah another real job
what they're excited about that that's
another real job yeah yeah did you ever
save anyone's life uh well in a way what
does this mean
well like I didn't I wasn't like um it
wasn't like Baywatch necessarily it was
more like I was like I guarded the beach
like meaning there was like a public
beach and a private beach and I had to
tell people to not come onto the private
beach oh
so like you were the person to remind
them of what level they were at
the people who are having fun over here
you're not allowed there but like it was
more like it was it was just like a mark
guy just a boundary marker you know and
I and I most of the times had to get up
and be like sorry and then people were
just pissed you know yeah and uh like a
a beach bouncer basically that's exactly
whatever yeah that's better actually
that's cool sounds cool yeah but then I
also had to do other things like first
aid and stuff like that that's cool yeah
that was I actually took a class like I
know how to do CPR I enjoy learning
stuff like that I do too it's really
important yeah I think it's really
important yeah I think it's good when I
had kids I was like don't die I did
everything to learn to like for them not
to die that's a good plan yeah I mean
just I feel like I'm killing it yeah
killing it
um yeah anyway so the thing is is that
I respect that you're hard working at
your normal job
um
[Applause]
my fake one but the thing is is that I
like one time somebody got stung by a
jellyfish like a man of war oh I've been
stung by jellyfish it's no fun yeah like
a big one or like a tiny one I don't
know how big it was but it hurt like
hell and I had to pee on myself yeah
they were like you got to pee on
yourself and everybody's like she's not
gonna be able to do it and I was like
going
I was like will it take away the burn I
will pee on in front of anyone maybe
well I uh that's what I had that's what
I decided
well they told me that that was what you
had to do and a person was in pain
I I suggested I I suggested that that
they that we should use p is what I
suggested it and and um they they at
that point you know the pain of us of a
jellyfish thing they would they would
they wanted it they would take anything
really they could
huh well I didn't really pee on them oh
okay I took
I took
a cup
okay
I just really need to do what you need
to sometimes I tell you what Save a Life
you know what I mean
[Music]
[Applause]